i think there's i think the
interdimensional spaces it will be next
i think we're going to start exploring
that i really do like what we're doing
i've been talking dmt true true i've
been talking to too many uh alien
abductees who believe that um you know
the aliens are us from or versions of us
from other dimensions
outer space like let's uh let's hear
some of these stories what's what's
what's really
with the aliens yeah like have you heard
a story that's kind of like rocked you
to your core
i wish i could say that but i i have met
people who are
because i'm such a skeptic
like i i that's what i want to believe i
really do want to believe and i'm
willing to talk to everybody but i've
met i met one person in particular
we talked for like two hours before we
got to aliens normal stuff newspapers
just like media
culture
really really got down and you were like
who'd you vote for and he was like oh my
god oh and by the way i was backed by it
oh yeah basically basically i was just
like so about the abduction story um and
he's been abducted since he was nine
and he's he has a support group for ufo
abductees or people who've had
encounters and so they show these
stories but he's been abducted since he
was nine
and he has very very vivid memories of
being lifted out of his window
looking over uh peekskill new york which
is the town where the yellow brick road
was the original yellow brick road wow
yep and um and and kind of hovering over
the trees and he believes that uh the
beings that come for him
are like avatars
for beings that can't travel
um from other if they're far away play
from like far away planets he's like
they're they're controlling them because
they have like a hive mind and they're
like opening his skull and he and he
says he wakes up feeling these things
and
he has a phd in the spiritual awakening
of being abducted it's fascinating like
he's an actual phd or you're just saying
figuratively no yeah yeah not like me
where i bought one for 20 dollars he has
an actual one so he thinks that they're
electromagnetic drones essentially like
they're pilots they're electromagnetic i
don't know if he knows he's touched he
says he's touched them and they they
have a uh like a hot sensation he
remembers like recoiling but this has
been happening since to him since he was
nine
and they keep coming for him different
ones
you know we all know about the grays
that's what i asked him so he also
claims to be like a psychic
and i asked him if it are the aliens
coming
are you a psychic as a consequence of
the abductions or
because you're a psychic is that why
they're coming to you because he would
he would fix computers for a living in
like the 70s after he got back from
vietnam 70s 80s he's running around
fixing like machines and computers
he never talked about
being abducted because there was a
stigma you don't want to talk about that
with people
so but people would keep coming up to
him and just talking about being
abducted
they had the urge to tell him like
they're weird not abduction stories all
the time but like we saw ufo something
like that
and then uh you know i think his wife
might have been the first person he told
you know after uh
30 years of not telling anybody
so
i want to say i believe him you know
he's
he's it sounds crazy like he sounds
his story is like i sounds legit to me
like
but i also think
sometimes people might confuse
horrible dreams
and their reoccurring nightmare but i
also have then
listened to um
different psychiatrists who say there's
no way to like
have trauma from such an experience like
these people who claim to be abducted
they have some type of trauma they can
be hypnotized and they relive it i know
people i've known people throughout my
life with schizophrenia
and i have heard stories about weird
government abductions and experiments
and i'm just like the things they say
are overtly insane
it's one thing to be like you need to
believe me man guys in suits came to my
house yesterday and i'd be like okay i
mean but when they say things like they
have nano technology devices that
they've injected me with that cause
invisible cameras to circle that my head
at all times and i'm like
nothing's happening am i missing it
where is it can you tell me where it is
i'm like that's you know objectively
nuts i have a theory about schizophrenia
i think they're plugged in to a
a mind level that we don't understand
it's kind of it's kind of a sad thought
though i mean some people may just have
misfiring brains for sure you know and
they need help but
yeah i'm like what if my friend is
telling me the truth they're actually
seeing something that's that's real and
we're just sitting here like because
look i've had friends who are
they can have a conversation and they
can tell you like this is a bottle of
water i need to drink water and eat food
i went to work today and then they'll
say something like i can see the beings
and you're and people will tell them
they're crazy and they're schizophrenic
and it's just like imagine if they
really did like in the sixth sense the
kid can see the dead people but they
just tell him he's crazy or in um
constantine's a good example
in uh in constantine the movie he's like
growing up he could see all these things
he could see the angels and the demons
and then nobody believed and they
thought he was crazy and they put him in
hospitals imagine being told you're
crazy when you're the one who's right
because you can see something that
people can't do that's like the problem
i was gonna talk about okay yeah but
yeah true friend
you're crazy that's not real it never
happened
did they just confirm that though yeah
it took the corporate media but um
i think schizophrenia
people with schizophrenia
are kind of plugged into a like an
information dump right they can't turn
it off and not to say that kids are
schizophrenic but there's a there's a
lack of filter between them and the
world like i think when we grow up we
start to uh take on all of like the
substance of materialism and then we
start we start to think of like uh
just the routine of life but kids are
still thinking about aliens and ghosts
and monsters like my five-year-old all
the time every night that's all we talk
about and when i talked i had a friend
with schizophrenic as well that's all he
talked about i'm like maybe they're just
like sensing something that we just
can't perceive right now um or yeah my
kid is just crazy no i think remote v
viewing that's a cia project the cia
investigates it because it's that
seemingly legit and there's stories
about people that die
no not yet yeah project looking glass i
think maybe is something that's targeted
was the one and i think it changed names
yeah and then you get this these
anecdotal stories of people that die on
the operating table and then they they
are above their body watching and they
hear the doctors saying things and then
somehow they come back to life after a
couple minutes and then they they recall
the conversation the doctor was like how
did you remember because they were they
were there on the bed maybe they were
dead but they weren't
completely unconscious crazy but they
see themselves from above you know yeah
but that and they see them like what
color she was wearing and yes but if so
the problem with standing the problem
with that is is you know you could be
semi-conscious and see a pink pink
scrubs and see a doctor you hear what
they say and afterwards you're like you
were talking about your football game
and the nurse was wearing pink scrubs
and like how did you know that but the
crazier stuff i read about was that they
would put numbers on the tops of things
and there were people who could tell you
they'd be like on the top of the monitor
was the number six and they would be
like
what so you could be like you weren't
able to see measuring i'm probably
bastardizing you the word mag vibration
but you can measure the vibration around
you and basically measure the matrix all
you need to know is where something is
how much of it there is and what it is
and then you can map that onto a
three-dimensional grid on the xyz axis
and build the matrix so if you're
feeling the vibration of the matrix you
may be able to calculate what everything
is that's causing that vibration and
maybe on some subtle level people are
picking up on that because how else
would you see a six on top of a monitor
they would have like
cards and stuff with information on it
that could only be seen from looking
down
and there would be people who would be
like i saw this card and it said these
things they'd be like whoa
i was trying to help solve a serial
killer case a few years ago the long
island series long island serial killer
and through that i was talking to some
cops who used people who tried remote
viewing to find bodies because this
particular killer left like a basically
a graveyard in long island
body parts all over the place that would
match with other parts of long island it
was and parts that were there for like
one part they found a torso in the
middle of long island they found the
hands 30 years later whoa yeah
but there was a guy in norway and a guy
i think in jersey who were trying to
like find
you know remote view you know and the
guy in norway supposedly according to
the reports out there i talked to him he
helped find a body
and just sitting in a room just like
doing what he does i i tried reaching
out to him to help find
some some people because we still don't
know who some of the victims are
but they like he act they gave them
information doesn't that person go away
but don't they become a suspect at that
point
he should where's the body at home
yeah i had this great source and now
he's in jail
you should uh you should uh i don't know
if i told this before look you should
check out the the istal woman and the
talmud shut case yeah you did that's
yeah the ice woman of norway dude it's a
crazy story what was it what was that
deal was it a woman was found like dead
of smoke inhalation with a bunch of
passports or something right and there's
a bunch of like questions about who she
was how she died and i think the
prevailing theory is that she was a
mossad agent tracking down nazis
and one of the nazis she was tracking
down to assassinate got the best of her
oh that's good crazy stories yeah no
we're good you know this is what's
really crazy is like i think about
history
i think about stories like that
and i'm like you know the craziest thing
is
a large portion of our history is
probably
the result of a deep conspiracy we'll
never know about true history is
probably long forgotten and long lost
because you can look at it today a news
article will come out and they'll say
something that's like technically the
truth
you know and then uh i'll give you a
good example like newsweek wrote about
the trump supporters wanting to secede
and the biden voters also agree and they
said trump voters want the country to
break apart what they didn't include was
like yeah but 41 percent of biden voters
agreeing is like a substantive number so
it's not only trump supporters but
history will record the framing of it so
i think back to like
you know there are a lot of people who
are like i don't appreciate how you said
this about this person because it makes
it sound like x when it's more like why
and some people just disagree on framing
when you look back at history history
being written by the winners it's not
just that it's like
you know we hear these famous quotes
benjamin franklin is better than 100
guilty persons escaped and one innocent
person suffer and he could have maybe
what he said or wrote down was
substantially more crass or crude and
then later on someone who knows and
loved him said i'm gonna remove that
swear word thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time